OTHERWISE, IT'S TIME TO UNITE
AND FIGHT.
THAT'S THE ANGLE.
ALL RIGHT.
JOINING ME NOW IS JOSH HAWLEY,
MISSOURI SENATOR.
WE'RE WATCHING THESE RESULTS
COME IN.
VERY CLOSE AT THIS MOMENT IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
YOUR REACTION TO THE ANGLE
SPECIFICALLY PUTTING THE PETTY
SQUABBLES OF THE PRIMARIES
BEHIND US AND MOVING FORWARD TO
WINNING IN NOVEMBER.
>> I WOULD JUST SAY, LAURA, YOU
GOT IT RIGHT.
TO ALL OF THOSE IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WHEN IT COMES
TO THE SQUABBLES THAT HAVE TRIED
TO GIN UP A WAR BETWEEN THE
TRUMP OR POPULOUS WING OF THE
PARTY AND THE ESTABLISHMENT
REPUBLICANS, IT'S TIME TO ADMIT
DEFEAT ON THAT.
THE VOTERS IN THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARIES HAVE MADE CLEAR WHAT
THEY WANT.
AN AGENDA FOCUSED ON THEIR
NEEDS.
THERE IS NO WAR IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THE REPUBLICAN VOTERS HAVE MADE
IT VERY CLEAR.
NOW IT'S TIME TO UNITE BEHIND
THAT POPULOUS AGENDA AND DRIVE
IT TO VICTORY IN NOVEMBER.
>> Laura: WELL, MEANWHILE, WE
HAVE A TWIST WITH MITCH
McCONNELL WHO HAS COME OUT AND
HAS USED THE I WORD, AND IT'S
NOT INGRAM, BUT IT'S
ISOLATIONIST WHEN HE WAS
DESCRIBING WHERE I GUESS YOU AND
OTHERS OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE LIKE
MYSELF AND TUCKER PERHAPS AT
FOX, THEY JUST DON'T WANT TO
SEND BILLIONS AND BILLIONS TO
UKRAINE.
SO IS THE ISOLATIONISTS LABEL
FAIR OR A GOOD IDEA?
>> I WOULD SAY THAT WHAT I
DESCRIBE MYSELF AS, LAURA, AND
WHERE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE,
WE'RE NATIONALISTS.
MY CONCERN WITH THE UKRAINE AID
PACKAGE, $40 BILLION, IT'S NOT
NATIONAL SECURITY.
IT'S NATION BUILDING.
THIS IS BACK TO THE FAILED
POLICY IN AFGHANISTAN AND IRAQ
WHERE WE'RE LITERALLY FUNDING
THE UKRAINE GOVERNMENT.
THIS AID PACKAGE WOULD WRITE A
CHECK FOR $9 BILLION DIRECTLY TO
THE UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S IN ADDITION TO THE OTHER
MONEY.
I'M NOT FOR NATION BUILDING.
I'M FOR PUTTING THE NATIONAL
SECURITY OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FIRST.
THAT IS NATIONALISM.
THAT IS THE BEST TRADITION OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
IT'S TIME THAT WE GOT BACK TO
IT.
>> Laura: SEEMS LIKE THAT IS THE
MESSAGE FROM THESE PRIMARIES,
TOO, SO FAR.
PEOPLE ARE FOCUSED ON HOME.
FOCUSED ON THEIR FAMILIES, GAS
PRICES, FOOD PRICES, THE BORDER,
CRIME.
WANT THE BEST FOR UKRAINE.
WE'RE OUT OF DOUGH.
WE'RE BROKE, WE'RE WOKE AND
WE'RE BECOMING A JOKE.
IT RHYMES BUT SADLY HAPPENS TO
BE TRUE.
>> THE THING ABOUT THE UKRAINE
AID PACKAGE, YOU CAN BUILD A
BORDER WALL TWICE OVER WITH THAT
MONEY AND IT'S TIME THAT WE GOT
SERIOUS ABOUT THESE PRESSING
PRIORITIES.
BY THE WAY, WE HAVE OTHER
PRESSING PRIORITIES ABROAD AS
WELL LIKE CHINA.
A MASSIVE NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT.
SO THE TIME HAS COME TO BE
REALISTIC HERE AND PUT THE
NATIONAL SECURITY INTEREST OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FIRST.
THAT MEANS SECURING OUR BORDERS.
THAT MEANS TAKING CARE OF THE
CRIME WAVE HERE IN THIS COUNTRY
AND GETTING TOUGH ON CHINA.
>> Laura: WELL, THE TRUMP
TARIFFS ON CHINA ARE A REALLY
BIG DEAL.
THAT TOOK A LOT OF WORK ON HIS
PART.
BOB LIGHTHEISER AND MIKE POMPEO,
THEY KNOW A LOT ABOUT WHO IS THE
POPULOUS IN THIS PENNSYLVANIA
RACE BUT WE DON'T KNOW.
BUT ON THIS FRONT ON CHINA, ALL
THE PEOPLE WANT TO FOCUS ON
UKRAINE.
WHERE IS THE FOCUS ON THE
BIGGEST THREAT TO THE UNITED
STATES, THE CCP?
YOU NEVER HEAR THEM TALK ABOUT
THAT AS MUCH.
>> ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THIS IS NOT THE TIME CAN I JUST
SAY TO GO SOFT ON CHINA AND
REPEAL THE CHINA TARIFFS, WHICH
IS WHAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IS DOING.
THE PRESIDENT SAYING YEAH, WE'RE
LOOKING AT ROLLING BACK THESE
TARIFFS.
SOME REPUBLICANS WANT TO GO
ALONG WITH THAT.
DON'T DO IT.
THIS IS NOT THE TIME.
WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR INDUSTRY.
A TOTAL DISASTER A TOTAL WRONG
MOVE.
WE SHOULD BE SCREWING DOWN THE
RESTRICTIONS ON CHINA AND
GETTING TOUGHER ON CHINA,
BUILDING UP OUR OWN INDUSTRY AND
BRINGING THOSE JOBS BACK TO THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: THE BABY FORMULA THING
DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
CHINA BUT BRINGS THE POINT HOME.
WE HAVE TO MAKE ESSENTIAL
ELEMENTS TO OUR DAILY LIVES
HERE.
WE HAVE TO MAKE MORE STUFF HERE.
THE FREE TRADE IS LIKE OH, FREE
TRADE.
BUT WE'RE SEEING WHAT IS
HAPPENING AS A RESULT.
WE'RE SEEING SHORTAGES, CARS,
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN'T GET
HERE NOW, PARTS, WE HAVE TO --
THAT PLAYING FIELD HAS TO BE
LEVELLED.
>> AND ONE OF THE BEST WAYS TO
BRING DOWN INFLATION IS TO BRING
BACK THE SUPPLY CHAINS SO WE'RE
NOT DEPENDENT ON CHINA.
WHY IN THE WORLD WOULD WE WANT
OUR CRITICAL GOODS, CRITICAL
MANUFACTURING, OUR CRITICAL
DRUGS AND OTHER DEVICES TO BE
MADE IN CHINA?
IT'S INSANE.
THIS IS THE KIND OF NATIONALIST
FOREIGN POLICY THAT WE NEED,
SOMETHING FOCUSING ON BUILDING
UP THE UNITED STATES, GOING TO
GET TOUGH ON OUR ENEMIES AND
OPPONENTS AND WILL PUT NATIONAL
SECURITY OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FIRST.
>> Laura: